okay so the next speaker is uh rishi
Gupta to tell us about a pack approach
to application-specific
yeah
yes
oh thank you and it's great to be here
I'd like to start with a bit of
motivation and setup for a way I'm gonna
talk about so throughout this talk we're
basically going to have a problem and a
set of algorithms and the goal is going
to be to pick from a set of algorithms
which algorithm is best so this is not
all of them to design this is going to
be algorithm selection and just an
example like say we have some problem
like independent set we might have a
bunch of algorithms that we like know
might be the right algorithm to use and
you know theory gives already has for a
lot of pretty much for this you know
they're by some theory would be well
pick a framework based on maybe well you
know about your instance the framework
will like ranked the three algorithms
that we have and I need it'll give a
score for each algorithm and then you
pick the algorithm with the best score
even this is nice in a couple of ways
you know a lot of you use what you know
about the instance so say you know your
independent set and since it's going to
be it's like planar or something there
might be a special algorithm for that
and a special analysis for that you know
say you've seen a million of these
instances before or you sort of you can
maybe guess a distribution and use
average case analysis and so so where
this where does this break down I don't
give in the next few slides I'm going to
give a few like very practical examples
of this algorithm selection problem and
here's some of the things that I'm gonna
try to point out there one is that your
instances the problems that you're
solving might have a lot of structure
but you might not know very cleanly what
that structure is right so planar is
like a super clear super easy to state
and sees the thing but like a lot of
instances in practice have a lot of
structure but without like such a clean
label secondly the structure often does
matter so like the best algorithm for
particular instance is not necessarily
going to be the one that's suggested by
a model that imposes no structure at all
sometimes you like may not even know
what the algorithm is so in the previous
slide we you know listed three
algorithms but really for solving
independence and
this may be we're just gonna go on the
internet Google for an independent set
algorithm and download it from the
internet and then often like even once
you've chosen your algorithm there might
still be more choices to make
like setting parameter values and so
sort of the question that motivated this
work is in the situation where you know
you have instances but don't really know
much about them you know that these
instances matter you have a bunch of
algorithms you like only barely
understand the algorithms and there's
still a little choices to make you know
how can theory sort of help someone go
through this process and so the first of
two examples I wanted to go through is a
graph coloring and so on this chart each
point here is a graph coloring instance
from one of twelve different sources and
the authors of this chart ran six
different algorithms on each of these
graph coloring instances and colored
each point based on which algorithm did
best so great hair means that like to
all of them like the best to you all
over them is tied so and then if it's
color it means that some algorithm did
strictly better than any other algorithm
in the set as you can see we have like
the first three of the four things I
mentioned above you know this is the duo
structure but you know it's like now I
claim that the structure has been
articulated but this chart probably took
you know 100 or more hours to make the
structure matters depending on what
exactly your instance is different
algorithms do better than others and
here you know none of these are
algorithms you'd find in a textbook
these are sort of very complicated
algorithms each of which is probably
over a thousand lines of code another
very exciting application that's going
on right now is the broadcast television
incentive auction running in the United
States and this is a two part option the
first part is the US government the FCC
is going to buy about 15 billion dollars
worth of broadcast TV licenses to like
TV channels essentially
it's going to after buying all these
licenses is going to repackage all the
existing TV license TV like podcast
channels and with the freed up channels
is going to sell them to people like
Verizon and AT&T to convert them into 4G
as you can see this like a pretty big
deal I think this is gonna be like five
percent of the u.s. deficit or something
probably gonna go that you know credit
all got the wrong place but and so what
what's computationally interesting about
this problem is that it's very similar
to the problem of sort of choosing
independent sets
so essentially what the FCC wants to do
is it wants to buy so the the way these
are broadcast channels work is there's a
bunch of towers and each tower broadcast
at a certain number of frequencies so
there may be like fifteen or twenty told
frequencies and each tower picks a
subset of those frequencies to broadcast
that and the main constraint is that if
two towers are geographically close they
can't broadcast on any of the same
channels and so the goal here is
basically at the end of stage one of the
option the by phase they're going to FCC
will not own a certain number of
channels in each tower and then it's
basically gonna convert so they might
have like four from tower a and five
from tower B in the six dome tower C and
so on it's going to convert those into
independent sets and each independent
set is going to turn into a new 4G
frequency and then everyone else is
going to tend to be repackaged into like
a fewer number of of channels yeah each
station can only broadcast one each
tower can broadcast on multiple yeah
exactly so why isn't it more like a list
coloring with
well yeah I guess this is closer to it's
more like a packing problem on the other
end we're coloring so every every tower
has a multiset right that unlike a set
of frequencies and north to adjacent
towers oh I see yeah yeah so so the
individual broadcaster is only on a
single channel on each tower
so the thing bacon buy and sell you
can't buy in cell towers but you can buy
and sell one channel on a tower channel
by channel space this isn't like for
fixing a channel a channel it's an
independent set across all the towers so
the current stated every channel loves
an independent set right so everyone by
the channel come at our hair yeah well
there are people by channel comment our
repairs but the reassignment here so
current so the current state is there's
like 20 independent sets basically and
that's these he's going to buy sort of
tower comma channel pairs and then sort
of real able everything to fit to like
separate out into like four G channels
and broadcast channels
and so in this case the auction
mechanism is basically fixed for a
variety of reasons the way it works is
basically every broadcaster said
broadcaster here's now at our common
channel pair is going to be offered an
initial price based on something and
then sort of every step of the clock all
the prices drop by on 1% or whatever and
then people can leave whenever they want
and then at some point the FCC says ok
we're done and then it buys everyone
who's left at the other price set you
know the clock is currently at and the
goal here is basically to set initial
prices so that you buy out the people
that you want right so the FCC can't
actually go and and force people to sell
things to it but you can sort of like
set the initial prices to like motivate
the right behavior and you know what is
the FCC wow that's is he wants to buy
licenses that are not worth very much
just for like social welfare purposes
and then also channels I don't interfere
much so channels and towers I don't
interfere much because this will be the
easiest to repack into into 4G and here
we see an example of the last thing that
I mentioned where like even once we have
the algorithm and we basically even know
like what we want to trade off it's not
really clear how one wants to trade off
sort of like how much to trade off the
first value of like so it's a lot fairer
versus like the second thing of sort of
getting a lot of independent sets I'm
not sure I mean maybe the phrasing isn't
quite clear yeah how does it work the
reverse option
yeah so basically every single
broadcaster is offered a price and again
it's starting price - in price no a
different price yes everybody's Pepsi
tea
so that's right so that's that's where
the discriminate price discriminate
well I'll tell you how they chose it
yeah that's not requires all four
different prices for the sellers right
so like if you have a tower in San
Francisco that should be worth more than
a tower and like Walnut Creek right
because Walnut Creek only has 40
thousand people on San Francisco as a
million people who is buying go sense
but populations we did so they already
know and she's here by its bank our
state yeah so this is actually only the
buying phase I should have been clear so
it's the only the bank pays and they run
through separately firstly by than your
repack and then you sell and you're not
talking about the second yeah I'm not
gonna talk about as long yeah yeah
that's a good clarification all right my
question is what's your the initial
price P and so you know once again soon
as you could offer basically just
directly proportional to population so
then now this is going to consider
anything so what after after the FCC has
bought a bunch of stuff it's gonna has
form those and two independent sets but
that's not what is talking well so
that's his goal is basically to buy the
right things right after my goal is
doing but ultimately goal that he sees
to buy things that are both not valuable
currently to broadcasters and that also
will strategically end up in a good
number of independent sets
and so exactly so the question here is
like for the baby see how do you how do
you make these how do you make this
trade-off and so they decided that is
gonna be a trade-off of the form V times
like C to some exponent so a B is some
their guests as so the value of the
station and C is sort of a the number of
conflicts they have with other stations
the question is like how do you choose
the exponent or the point five here and
the weighted it is it basically there
and a bunch of simulations using
basically different models in which they
could have messed up V and for each way
in which they think they could have
gotten be wrong they sort of run the
simulation with different exponents and
then they took the exponent which they
see which was best and I think the
actual best sex when it was like 0.56 or
something and then it got rounded off to
point five for political reasons well so
those are the two examples that sort of
motivated this work and to reminder the
general set up is we have a source of
problem instances like for instance in
graph coloring or in making simulations
from the FCC case we have a family of
algorithms and our task is to pick which
algorithm to run and just to keep things
straight forward for the talk so stuff
in the paper is quite general but for
this talk when I say problem let's just
imagine like the Senate set problem and
for the algorithms let's just think
about the FCC algorithms essentially or
some it's actually surprisingly close to
the actual SEC algorithm even though
that's an auction and this is an
algorithm but basically the our
algorithms for independent set are going
to be a set of greedy algorithms we Nero
is you take every vertex you give it a
score that is its weight divided by you
know essentially the number of conflicts
to the row that gives a ranking over
vertices and I need to sort of pick them
in a greedy fashion
so if row 0 then it's probably easiest
to see now you're just ordering the
vertices by weight and picking vertices
as you can see picked before that kills
all the threes and now you're left with
picking the 2 instead of 6 no this is
just to show that like this or it
matters which greedy algorithm you
choose
algorithms alone that give you different
answers in the end and a petition we're
gonna use a sub row to mean just this
greedy algorithm using row sorry what's
this hard looking for now this is just
so we needed for the rest of the talk we
need for a sample a problem a sample set
of algorithms to pick from so these are
these are just greedy algorithms for
independent set we're gonna pin a set
yeah I mean yeah our metric family of
algorithms so that the task is basically
going to be given a sort of source of
independent set instances we want a way
to pick row essentially to pick an
algorithm from this family of algorithms
yeah so arrow is just going to be the
the greedy algorithm with this parameter
value row
and the exponent so in weight divided by
degree plus went to the row yeah yeah so
that's the definition exactly
yeah and so sort of the main
contribution of this work is or these
two models first sort of thinking about
this problem when is her inspired by
online learning and the other one
inspired by pack learning and I think
one of the strengths of this is even
though this is sort of like a problem
that's not necessarily looked at in
algorithms like Auto and selection
hopefully the theory will feel at least
somewhat somewhat familiar ok any
questions so far before I get into the
the models
well okay so the first model I'm gonna
talk about online or the sort of online
learning model and read a bunch of text
but you can just follow on along the
pictures so here there is the basic a
learner and an adversary the learner is
gonna be trying to learn the algorithm
and the sort of the model proceeds in
rounds so on the first day or on the
first round the learner picks an
algorithm essentially arbitrarily
because it doesn't know what's gonna
happen the adversary then picks an
independent set instance whichever one
it wants and then the learner gets a
score and the score is gonna basically
be you run the algorithm on the instance
and you see what what you get and then -
the same thing happens the learner picks
an algorithm not a learner and gets to
see what happened on the previous day it
can use a however it wants fix an
algorithm the adversary gets to see the
algorithm that learner chose it picks an
instance and the learner gets a score
and so this basically continues as long
as you want and note that I mean the
adversaries are unconstrained is
completely unconstrained at this point
right I mean the iris rarity picks the
instance after seeing what the you know
what the algorithm the learner is about
to run but then at the end that is
really basically forced to pick a single
algorithm that's the benchmark algorithm
and and basically the adversary score is
this algorithm on the instances that it
has already picked and so and then the
sort of score the learner is essentially
or which is called regret is the average
sort of difference between what the
learner gotten what the adversary got I
said I researcher you can do basically
whatever it wants but it has to sort of
have in the back of its mind a single
algorithm that you know it's going to
perform well against and the goal in
online learning in general is basically
to have some procedure for the learner
that causes it for the average of regret
to to go to zero as T goes to infinity
so basically over time when you want to
strategy for the learner to get like
closer and closer an objective value to
this benchmark algorithm essentially and
just to know like I've not talked about
any computational restrictions so far
it's not a part of the actual model and
then just some technical conditions the
payoff so for the learner the payoff is
basically you run the so basically
there's a bunch of instances that your
study is chosen and then the learner has
a bunch of algorithms as chosen so it
runs the algorithm on the you know the
Italian on the ithe instance and then
another iris area runs this algorithm
and then the difference between those
scores oh yeah sorry solution quality
yeah it's like a number the total weight
besides isn't gonna set yeah so
difference between there's a weight so
the adversarial basically gets them
independent set and the learner all
we've got some independent set honey
today so that I research on some
benchmark algorithm and so the learners
algorithm and the adversary's algorithm
will both result in some independent set
with some weight and then just the
difference between those is the S right
it's like a negative score
now the goal is for that to go to zero
over time basically I mean we don't know
what's the benchmark everything I've
said so far is is sort of the standard
online learning framework so there's no
benchmark it's just best in hindsight
yeah yeah we're calling it benchmark but
yeah best in hindsight is yeah that's
exactly that's that's all I mean yeah
yeah and in fact maybe to make it even
more more explicit so in the normal
learning with from experts model they're
a bunch of experts so here our
algorithms are the experts in the normal
sort of online learning model the iris
forgets to like declare an arbitrary
cost vector on each round and here
slightly weaker the adversary gets to
choose an arbitrary instance and the
instance herb induces this cost vector
so that's the main difference and so
there there's a standard technique in
for online learning problems
multiplicative weights and so it's sort
of natural first thing to try it turns
out not to work for a couple of reasons
sort of not that important reason is
that there's an infinite number of
experts so multiplicative weights
traditionally you know there's there
like an N a number of experts and you
have bounds in terms of n but there's
sort of a number of ways around that
including often you just take like an
epsilon net of the experts or so on so
the more the more serious problem is
actually that our cost vector is not
well behaved so in sort of settings
where you can sort of turn your an
infinite set of experts into a sort of
finite subset I sort of need the
property that like experts that are
close by to each other sort of perform
similarly and that is like very much not
the case here you could have so our two
algorithms like an a 0.51 and a sub 0.5
one one and those could just have their
arbitrarily different behavior so it's
not clear how you could sort of form an
epsilon net essentially of your experts
and in fact so the first sort of quick
where's all something I talk about from
our paper is that it is in fact not
possible to get to get no regret and
just to get like a quick feel of why
this is the case basically the Irish
surely can choose independence at
instances such that the sort of cost
vector has an arbitrary square square
function essentially so the instances
would look like this and basically the
you can sort of choose the weights on a
B and C such that sort of there's like
this precise row at which you can choose
this is that all the weight is on B and
you can start pick the weight such that
there's like this precise row at what
you get you know all of B and if Rho is
too small then you like take it all of a
first and that kills off B and Rose too
big you like you know pick C first and I
kills off all B as well and so the
strategy for the adversary is basically
on day one you like you said I pick some
roast are you keep it in the back of
your head you pick some square around
roast are and on each day you sort of
shrink that shrink that square by like
you know a factor of n or something and
so you know the learner UNIF it knows
exactly what happened on the first I
days even if it knows exactly what the
adversary is trying to do there's sort
of no way for the learner to guess where
to where to go on the on the I plus
first day yep not possible do you mean
not possible so if in a model where the
feedback you get is just like the costs
and you have to use one of these
particular algorithms or not possible
even if like maybe I have a totally
different algorithm the guarantees yeah
I can't type erratically not possible as
well like couldn't I maybe you know have
a polynomial time algorithm
yeah so this I just mean like like
there's not enough information for the
learner to do basically anything right
so like on this day let's say the
learner knows that I was like so
learners basically trying to guess for a
star in some sense yeah that's right the
learner only has to guess some things
are in this in this range so you're not
allowed to use any other I'll go ahead
and say only this particular oh I see
well you don't see the you don't see the
right that okay so you don't see the
graph right you don't see the graph
until you just see the graph after you
guess right so you choose an algorithm
then the adversary picks the graph has
to have to choose one of the killer
algorithms above this family you can't
choose any other yeah I'm gonna pound
sign oh yes yeah yeah yeah that's right
that's right I see what yeah yes it is
proper learning in that sense right
okay so but you know I probably want to
start on this direction if we didn't
have positive results and so we can't
get positive results under sort of - -
weakening of the the constraints so one
is rather than trying to get average of
yet going to zero we allow ourselves an
average regret of one over poly N and as
to the size of the number of vertices in
our independent set instances and
secondly we sort of restrict what the
adversary can do by adding smoothing to
the weights of independent set and then
with these two with these two things now
and now we can get sort of a positive
result which is the sort of standard
smooth food analysis type result which
is like yeah there's no he's in the
world or we can add it I mean there's
some process so the adversary basically
gets to pick a sentence and then some
noise is added to whatever that is sorry
Thanks um yeah I want can think of it as
noise in the world or as yeah you think
something like follow the protocol 800
yes I'll go through the proof of this in
the next two slides it's not all that
perturb leaders it just reduces to most
multiplicative weights the standard so
the end technique is going to be we end
up taking a like an epsilon net and then
gain multiple it of weights and then the
question is like why why does that work
which I'll get to in the next slide and
so the proof of the theorem is basically
there's two facts we're going to need
this first fact I'll go into more detail
on the slide after this but basically
for any independent set instance the
cost vector is a step function with only
paulien steps so this is sort of like
the main so the main thing we need from
our from early excited algorithms I'll
go into more in the next slide and then
back to is basically just that like if
you sum of the weights you actually get
smoothing
and there's a cross vector and so once
we have these two hopefully square that
you can sorta just take an epsilon net
and it'll work because we're with hi you
know friendly you for any one of these
independent set instances like if you
think it fine enough epsilon net because
because all the boundaries are alike
will be around a bit like you're
basically going to have at least one
person in your net on each one of the
sort of each one of these guys and
that's all you need to sort of cover all
the possible algorithm outcomes and then
multiple could a way so we'll give you
the best out of those that make sense
and so now the interesting part of this
is the fact one so why is a cost vector
of this sort of very restricted form is
that function with poly n steps and the
answer is basically that for any fixed
independent set instance we can so RB
algorithm is basically of the following
form we have a bunch of nodes we assign
each notice score that gives a ranking
of the nodes and then we sort of like
receive looking at you know we do some
greedy Ottoman where you look node by
node and so on this graph I've plotted
like a zero goes from zero to one this
or a score of each node I'm trying to
give a note it's gonna look like some
weight divided by you know some degree
to the row and sort of the important
point to note here is that like any two
of these lines couldn't only intersect
in exactly one place because you know
you sort of need that to be true and
that's all going to meet you in one
place and because of that you know
there's only n different nodes ants
there's only n square different
intersections and then for any you know
any between any two intersections sort
of the algorithm is always better
perform exactly the same because all we
care about is the ranking and so there's
actually only sort of for any given
independence an instance it only
unscored different places algorithm can
change there's only essentially n square
different algorithms
and so that's what allows this to be
possible
that's it from mobile one ten minutes
left
well I'm just gonna move out to model -
but are there any questions about this
simple procedure for actually
constructing this epsilon there so
that's one that is it's uh I mean you
just pick up one small enough like
whenever n to the fifth or something and
just yes you know take the natural yeah
yes literally yeah because al gore-ism
with all the rows of the epsilon then
every instance yeah
- aw okay why can't you just keep doing
that forever instead of learning
anything just pick this well so you have
to pick there uh before you see the
incidence is a tricky part of online
learning
no but in practice why don't you just
run all the you know all the instances
of the algorithm in parallel and pick
the best that's this is an optimization
problem so just pick the best results
okay well it's not one of the packages
in the class no III understand why the
rules of the game
why I think that other fundamental the
yeah I think the more phenomenal point
she brought up is that like the in this
model that there's like an adversarial
choice of the instance at every step
right so you can do so you can you can
look at all the past instances you can
run all their algorithm I mean there are
two models right it's like if you have a
model of where he's less adversarial
than the next model that we have is
going to be maybe more appropriate
not because of adversity or anything but
yeah the training stage for each one of
the instances enough time to run all day
any other piece I'll go with them and
also when the real instance comes to you
in the real life and then pick just the
best answer for anything would evasions
they accept solvers you don't want to
travel the trailer space right and then
also I also multiplicative weight says I
think it can vary a little bit faster
than just like the total naive way of
going about it
let me talk a little bit quickly about
the second model I think maybe a nice
code sitter is also this but the model
here is sort of so here that is where he
goes first the adversary picks a
distribution over instances and then the
mall here is basically more on the
traditional like training phase test
phase thing where that really has some
hidden distribution the learner draws
and samples and then has to pick an
algorithm just using those m samples and
then your score is basically how well we
do against the original distribution and
I mainly want to just draw the analogy
between traditional PAC learning for
very familiar so it's very very similar
cool
I'm patterning there's a notion of like
concepts and a concept class and I
thought hypothesis class so here our
concepts are just going to be some
normal path learning concept they're
essentially maps from your like
instances to boolean values so here very
similar our oblems are essentially maps
we think of as maps from instances to
real values and then impact learning or
learning this concept class or
hypothesis class and here both the
concept class and the hypothesis class
are our set of algorithms a and we end
up using techniques very similar to pack
learning and particular likes or the
standard to15 learning is is this notion
of like vc-dimension other set of
algorithms of a sort of kavas of a
hypothesis class or a concept class and
here we have a very similar notion of a
VC dimension of a set of algorithms
appropriately modified to for the real
valued case and then I just want to make
sure of time to go through go through
some of the results and so the reason
this formalization is pretty cool is
that a lot of like very natural family
that algorithms have very low
essentially VC dimension or pseudo
dimension so that when I talked about
this family greedy algorithms also a lot
of similar like local search families of
local search algorithms have VC
dimension log N and really again like
almost the only thing we use here is
that you know these algorithms have some
scoring role and then that scoring role
for like your vertices it or whatever
gives you a ranking over the vertices
and all we need here is that the ranking
has been change that often or that any
you know if you have to you know then
your some scoring role those you know
that graph basically can't have too many
intersections this is actually a very
sort of very weak restriction
on family to algorithms the algorithm
that you would describe in before was
sort of a single parameter algorithm yes
yeah so if you have like K parameters
you get another K in here so if you like
kale again I mean is there actually any
very I've not thought about it be very
surprising if it were just one because
like there's always a learning algorithm
that's exponential in D and I said I
would also imply a learning algorithm
that only had to look at like order of
one samples not five I completely by be
very surprised if there was something
less than well again
they were actually a one well you know a
lot of learning problems there's just
one parameter you often expect the VC
dimension to be one you know and so I'm
just wondering you know why or you know
the function is the same thing yeah man
I think that's every go yeah the fact
that there is like order like poly-a
steps suggest said it'd be very
surprising to you less than log n
connected to the the previous talk
so reinterpreted a part of so and their
self improving algorithms they're
basically sort of two parts step one is
that they were sighted algorithms that
probably like the best out of another
set works really well and then also
they're able to to learn it efficiently
and so just like restating the second
the second part of that in this
framework gives you a VC dimension value
of n to the one plus C we also have an
example of gradient descent where you
have a family of convex functions and
you're trying to pick a good step size
for gradient descent and again in this
and also in the smaller we don't like
computational aspects are not a part of
the model but for all the examples that
we have in the paper in here there isn't
there are in fact like polynomial time
algorithms cool and I think maybe I was
leave this up and and and
I actually have one with this app so it
seems like the algorithms or one family
logarithm to study our priority-based we
go sir yes so if this like a feature map
or something yeah that should be pretty
straightforward
I think we even work it out that
specification one of the examples on the
paper
okay so thank Russia again